elementary schoolers like two things for
sure cookies and dinosaurs and what's
better than dinosaurs and cookies
dinosaurs that are 3d cookies the trick
to cut out cookies is a malleable dough
we like cooks Illustrated's chewy
gingerbread recipe just make sure your
dough is very cold for optimal cookie
structure and please people wash your
hands each cookie cutter set contains
multiple parts once baked you can
decorate to your heart's content the
slip part here is the puzzle piece like
assembly sure the makers have taken a
few liberties with prehistoric Anatomy
hello t-rex has two fingers on its arms
but we think your kindergartner will
forgive the error if it's covered in
frosting